So, to build an app like this one for
location services and
many of the other services that you'll
be encountering in this course,
you're going to do the following steps.
First of all, the easiest way to
get started is to create a new
app using a Blank Activity
in Android Studio.
Once you've done this,
you'll edit the build.gradle
to add the services libraries.
You'll using something like this,
but the version number may change.
Then, you'll edit AndroidManifest.xml,
to tell your application that you're
using these services libraries, and the
particular version that you're using.
When you put this value,
integer Google Play services version.
When you do a gradle sync, the correct
version number will be put in for you.
So it's good just to use this string.
And then finally,
in AndroidManifest.xml you're
probably going to be adding
a bunch of permissions as well.
In this case I was doing location so
you see I set users permission for
access_fine_location.
Depending on the activity or depending
on the type of application that you're
building, you'll be putting
different permissions in here.